This is not 99% invisible, but I'm still Roman Mars. Every time my kids get in the car with me, the first thing I do is they crank up the AC. The kids run hot. I can't explain it. It doesn't matter whether it's like outside. That's what they do. And then the next thing they do is they ask, can we turn on Dear Hank and John. Dear Hank and John is an advice podcast featuringeng Green and John Green, who I'm guessing
you already know. They are both YouTube pioneers, educators, podcasters, number one best-selling authors, and they're just also simply great and kind people who's creative output and charity make the world a better place. The Dear Hengen John podcast is my twin's favorite, and so when I noticed that the show sometimes has guest hosts, I offered myself up as a substitute if nothing else just to impress my kids.
I had such a good time and we covered a lot of design and design stuff. I'd like to share it with you. Enjoy. Hello and welcome to Dear Hank and John. Or as I prefer to think of it, Dear Hank and Roman, I don't need to be first. I'm just having to be here. It's a podcast where two brothers and sometimes a brother and a guest answer your questions give you to be a surprise and bring you all the week's news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon. Roman, I heard that once you were at a bar and you were ordering drinks and you just held
up two fingers and then the waiter brought you five drinks. Do you know why? Because I'm Roman Mars. Because he thought you were using Roman numerals. Does that look like a... I love it. It works now. Everyone, I'm sure that everyone always thinks you're using Roman numerals. I didn't even think about the fact that your name was Roman Mars
until I was writing that joke. I was like, wow, Roman Mars, what a name. Well, thank you. I'm a big fan of Mars. Is Mars a Roman god or is he Greek? Mars is a Roman god. I think Aries is the equivalent to Greek mythology. Yeah. That's definitely something you should know.
Most people are making fun of my name. They'll say they'll say, oh is it 99% of visible with Greek Aries? That's what they usually do. They're trying to do it like a little thing. Yeah. Well, I'm not I didn't do that. I could easily have come up with that joke, but I didn't. I didn't even occur to me. Roman Mars is the host of 99% Invisible, a legendary podcast that continues to make lots of really amazing content. Whenever I think to myself, I'm bored.
I don't have anything to do. I think, but I haven't listened to every episode of 99% Invisible. So there is acres of curiosity and happiness to be had just around the corner. All I have to do is push like six buttons in a row. It does require six buttons. Unfortunately, these days are still, but still. Yeah, I'm grateful you listen.
That's great. Well, I mean, I should be able to set up some kind of shortcut where I can just like tap my glasses and your voice begins Well, I should say that dear Hank and John is like Between me and my twins we listen to this in the car like exclusively and this is like a very big deal show to them They do not listen to 99% invisible They've no interest in it whatsoever. They only listen to dear Hank and John. So this is like a interesting it whatsoever. They only listen to dear Hank and John. So this is like a very real honor to be here and they will be so excited. Well, that is an honor to be your family
podcast. How old are they? They're 15 years old. I have twins. As long as I'm a 15 years old. I haven't come up with one for I'm my five year old yet. Yeah. Because our tastes do not consistently overlap when it comes to podcasts. Or many things I would imagine. Yeah, a lot of the music he likes, I'm like, wow. That's great. I didn't get a true love for pop music, like kind of teeny pop music until my kids
sort of entered into that age of like five, six and those Disney Channel theme songs are like, these are really good. Somebody worked really hard on this. There's no doubt in my songs are like, these are really good. Somebody worked really hard on this. Like there's no doubt in my mind that like there were experts involved. Exactly. I like that about your work too,
that it reminds me that there are experts involved in so much and that oftentimes I will see a decision that was made. And before listening to 9-Anne Percent Visible, I might look at that and be like, what a stupid thing that choice was. But now, I listen and I'm like, I bet there was a very good reason why they did it that way.
Yeah. I mean, that's kind of the premise of the show, or why it's called 99% of visible, it's about design, is that most of the time, when it's good design, you don't notice it's invisible. The things that work, you don't notice, and the things you bang your head up against, you do notice. And so you kind of run across bad design a little bit more, like there's more friction with bad design, you think about it and hate it and and so like that. And it is probably likely that there is, you know, like a good amount of thought that went into the even the ones that you don't like for some other reason, some other. Yeah. Yeah. It was not. It was, it's bad for me,
but it's probably good for like the flow of water or something. Exactly. Because it turns out it's important, gosh, it turns out it's really important to get the water out of the cities. It is. That's one of the most important things. A very expensive prop. Exactly. So I've learned a great deal from you and I appreciate. Also, I've learned a lot from just how you work, and the work that you do and the creative enterprise that you have created. I love hearing from a variety of voices on 9 and NPI and that you have been able to take this thing that was
in your head and make it a thing that other people can do as well. Oh, thank you. It seems like that's the case anyway. And I assume that you don't have like a hundred percent control over everything that happens on the podcast. Yeah, no, we tried to build a little community around people and promote people.
And I'm just a huge fan of podcasting and radio in general. Like I got into this because I really truly loved it. I love the sound of people's voices. I love them talking. I love learning new things. I'm like a sponge for that sort of stuff. And so anytime we can sort of create more of that in the world, I'm super, super happy or or like promote whatever it is.
It makes me really pleased. Yeah. Speaking of design, I have a question. It comes from Chrissy. Who asks? Hi guys. Hey, that was not specific. Chrissy didn't know who she was going to reach. So there are a ton of people in the world who do not enjoy the task of flossing or brushing their teeth.
Do you think it would be possible to create a roomba for teeth for all of us lazy people out there? I get that it would be expensive to accidentally swallow a tiny robot, but there must be a way, not at a tententist's recommend, Chrissy. I don't think it's a good idea to have it be a tiny robot.
No, I don't think so either. But that doesn't mean that it's not a good idea. In fact, I was like, I wanted somebody must have thought of this. Somebody said to themselves, the toothbrush is 500 years old, there has to be a better way to do it. And indeed, I can't remember what it was called, but it looks like a mouthguard that you stick in and it's on a wand. And then it just like jiggles. And then you turn it upside down and it jiggles your bottom teeth and you're done in 30 seconds. It says,
it's like, in part pitched as an efficiency play where it's like, you spend too much time. Are you tired of all the time you waste a minute a day brushing your teeth cut at a half? And also it's pitched as a your children are terrible at this don't let them be. Yeah, the sort of idea of a robot sort of violating your personal body space to make you floss. It seems like a big mistake. But there have been real changes in in toothbrushes in particular like for a long time, those like toothbrushes were really skinny. The handles are really skinny. And they were like the big innovation in a toothbrush design was like the
reach toothbrush in the 70s that was angled, but it was angled like a dental. Do you remember the advertisements? I kind of do like where you, you can either get a flip top head or you can get a reach toothbrush. But those were made to look like dental tools that somebody else used on you, not for you to hold in your hand.
They were kind of like a weird, like it was mainly using the aesthetics of a dental tool. And then much later on, they came up with the fat handle toothbrush. Because they realized that sort of hand canesthesiologists felt that toothbrushes were like a little too narrow and they would roll in your hand as well.
And fat toothbrushes came around. And the big objection to fat toothbrushes was that a lot of mid-century modern homes had actual toothbrush holders in your bathroom that were built in by the construction company and they didn't fit. It was like it was a tile that was meant to modularily exist with all the other tiles. But those did not fit that toothbrush. Yeah, and you can't just go get like an angle grinder and just open it up a little.
No. And so that was a big moment of friction when they introduced the fat handled toothbrush. And I remember when the fat-hound toothbrush came out, the company that released them, actually you could mail in for a little stand to put your toothbrush on in case your home didn't have the right size toothbrush holder. So these are the cascading effects of
like any time of device that you get and how it interacts with the bell rust the belt world is a fascinating thing. Yeah, and now you can use that little toothbrush holder to hold your mouth scrubber. That's right. That you, like, on the end of a wand that you just shove into your mouth and sit there. Yeah. While you, I assume, listen to 99% visible. I don't think the big mistake here is efficiency. I've never seen anyone create enough efficiency in the life to do something really great with
that. So just take your time to your toothbrush. I find that I floss a lot more when I have some kind of dental problem. And I think that flossing is going to keep me from the edge of oblivion, right? Yeah. That's probably the wrong way to do it, but yeah, I agree. Exactly. But that's it.
And that's the only thing that gets me to floss. I understand you. I, I floss, um, two weeks after and two weeks before any dental appointment. And that is it. Exactly. My real strategy. All right. Roman, I have another question for you. It's, it's from Edward who asks, dear Hank and Roman, I understand that Hubble's law of cosmic expansion says that all galaxies are expanding away from each other. Do you? I understand that. I understand that someone has told me this. But is there anything between the galaxies? Are there any lone planets or dust or is it just completely empty space? And if there was anything, how would we
know? Like, do we have any proof that the space between galaxies isn't just filled with a bunch of chickens? Maybe that's why all the galaxies are expanding. It's the chickens and it's scaring the galaxies away. Not an Ed Letter, but an Ed word. Wow. It's Ed word. This is all you, Hank. That's all. Yeah.
Do you know that the galaxies are moving apart from each other? Yes, that I know. Do you know that there is lots of, like mostly it's space between galaxies and not galaxies? Yes. And there's a lot more stuff in a galaxy than not than like there is stuff in areas where there's a similar sized area where there wouldn't be a galaxy. Yeah. That all makes sense. All of these things are clear. Yeah. The
got us all that far. See, often here like cubic meters of space. So in like the intergalactic medium is what this called. There's like one, like maybe one particle per cubic meter and that's almost always a hydrogen ion. So it's just a proton. Is it, there's like one proton per cubic meter, which is about as empty as you get in our universe. Okay. Which isn't completely empty.
There's a proton there and a cubic meter is an understandable volume. Like, you can picture it in your head if you know what a meter is. That's pretty big. That's denser than I thought, actually. Yeah. Yeah. You thought, well, I mean, you may be imagining a proton is bigger than it is. That's probably true. I can see it written on a piece of paper. I can see it written on a piece of paper. Is that? No, but that makes sense to me. That's a understandable unit of a... Yeah.
And we know about this because we can see, like when we look at distant stuff, there's like, we can see a little less of it than we otherwise would be able to because there's a lot of cubic meters between us and there. And there are enough of these protons to absorb just a little bit of the light that's coming off of a quasar from a long way away. The question of whether it's full of chickens is an interesting one though, because it's definitely not full of chickens in that like if you were a chicken you you could see another chicken. Like that would, to me, like a chicken being able to like,
like being close enough to another chicken to be like, there's my other space chicken friend, Alfred. That's, that is not that full of chickens. But like, there is a number of chickens that could be in the intergalactic medium that we wouldn't notice. Yeah. I don't know how big that number is, but I bet it's bigger than you'd think. Well, that's the only thing that this question made me think is like, how many chickens would it
have to be before we noticed? It could be full of chickens. We just haven't trained the telescope in the right location yet. It, well, yeah, again, full is a, you know, it wouldn't be full. If it was full of chickens, they would crush themselves into a black hole. Yeah. Because that's how gravity works over time. But if it was a few,
Yeah. Some appreciable amount of chickens, you know. Yeah, you could have, you could have like two chickens per cubic light year, no problem. Yeah, that would be a whole amount of chickens, you know? Yeah, you could have, you could have like two chickens per cubic light year, no problem. Yeah, that would be a whole lot of chickens. And that would be a lot of chickens in the galaxy. Yeah.
But anyway, there are the things, so it's not just protons, that's the average density. So there will be rogue stars in the intergalactic medium that have been ejected from their galaxies. There will be rogue planets that have been ejected from their galaxies. That's just very cool to think about. There are almost definitely star systems in our universe with no stars in the sky
because they are that far away from any galaxy. Hmm. So instead of looking up and seeing stars, they look up and they see pure velvet black, with maybe a couple of smudges of distant galaxies. Or, and then hopefully at some point they see a chicken. Just floating by. Wouldn't that be so surprising if all the time you saw velvety black and then just a chicken
floated by. How much would that change your world? I mean, it'd be a big deal. It'd be a really big deal. It would especially be a big deal if it were anatomically and genetically a chicken. That would really, that would really throw us for a loop. We'd have a lot of rethinking to do. This next question, Roman, is from Seth, who asks,
dear Hank and Roman, we often hear the phrase, as science continues to advance, this problem will be easier to solve. What exactly are these scientific advancements that are always supposedly happening, and who is doing the advancing of them? Is it scientists or engineers, or is it maybe computers? I haven't listened back far enough yet to understand pumpkins and penguins.
So pairs and porcupines, Seth, when Roman emailed me about maybe coming on the podcast to sign off the N.P. Roman, which was pretty crazy. That's just to let you know I'm a real fan, not pretending. That's right. That's right. Roman, what does that mean? Do you have an idea of how progress occurs? A scientific advancements? Do you think about this in a sort of a historical way? Yeah. Well, usually a scientific advancement is a kind of iterative process.
And we get a narrow window into those moments of punctuation when things like really advance, and they sort of percolate up into the sort of consciousness of, you know, popular culture. I would say that, you know, how does scientific advancements, I think one is sort of computing power as a huge one that sort of changed the way that things, you know, we can sort of crunch enough numbers to come out with things to model. And I think that's a big part of how advancement happens. I try to think about other sort of techniques. There's often these just gigantic movements. Like, when I was right before I sort of started grad school while I was in college and studying
genetics, PCR polymerase chain reactions has started as a technique to sort of amplify DNA. as a technique to sort of amplify DNA. And it was this revolution in how people understood DNA and the different assays you could create to like study small samples of DNA. And it is basically a technique that they took to become like this incredible scientific tool. And these are things just kind of like crop up and happen and then all of a sudden your ability
to like examine new things. It's just increased just like exponentially. Yeah. And then you combine that technology with advances in computing technology with like maybe even advances in like how do you organize and manage humans technology and connect humans for like who are in you know far away places who wouldn't normally be sharing research technology and all that stuff like adds on to each other. Yeah. Yeah. But like the weird thing is that there is a there's kind of a sense and in the way that we talk about it that all of these things are kind of inevitabilities and that like progress occurs and that our understanding of the universe continues, but every single one
of those things was done by a person. Oh, for sure. None of it. All of every one of the computers was programmed by a person. And we know that. We know that objectively, but it is often talked about as something that just happened.
And I think we talk about it that way, because it wasn't done by any one person. And so it just seems like it was something that just happened because it was done by tens of thousands of people. And so if there was a story where like one lab came together and you know, you can tell that story with PCR, you can tell the story of how that happened. And for example, a great example of this is like the story of how an mRNA protein manufacturing process works, where you deliver mRNA into a cell, and the cell manufactures the protein that you want it to, or that the doctor
wants it to. And like that, you know, is a many decades-long process of figuring out how that works, and it allowed us to create COVID vaccines really fast that were really effective, that have saved millions and millions of lives. But there isn't a person who was responsible for that. And there wasn't even, there wasn't a lab, there wasn't a school, there wasn't, it was a truly international and whole species endeavor to figure that out.
And so it seems inevitable and it seems like something that just happens when really it is a, and you can speed these things up by having more people dedicating more time to doing these kinds of things. Totally. And that's one of the best parts of progress in science. And one of the things that, you know, on the show that I do, we don't tend to cover a kind of new design. We tend to cover, it's basically a history show wrapped up in this idea because I'm much more interested in the effects of these types of things, rather than in how it says about us as humans and society, than the story of a great person coming up with a great
thing. Sometimes those stories are fun to listen to, but they don't really tell you the whole story of most things when it comes to progress. Yeah. I have a question here from Alice. I don't have an answer. I have a couple of answers that I think are probably bogus. Do you hear Hank and Roman? What was the first thing bought on the internet?
And more importantly, I think for this conversation, do you remember the first thing you ever bought online? Yours from the information super highway, Alice. Could all information super highway. It is quite a highway. It is the speeds of, I feel like maybe we need a speed limit. In fact, sometimes I do have a speed limit,
like when I'm on vacation, like the internet's really bad at the hotel I'm at or on an airplane and the internet's really slow or I don't wanna pay for it. But I still have my computer. I'm at or on an airplane and the internet's really slow or I don't want to pay for it. But I still have my computer. I'm like, actually, this might be better. I'm 56K might have been the ideal speed for information to enter into my device. Maybe we should stick with that. It does sort of limit to the, but limiting the pipeline just sort of changes what you decide that you can, it's really like it makes me more productive.
Yeah. Yeah. I looked this up a little bit and there was one source said that it was likely a bag of marijuana, which was not surprising. It does sort of seem like what, probably the, and then another was telling me that it was a CD, like a music,
And then another was telling me that it was a CD, like a music, disc that was sold in 1994 for $12 and something. And I was like, no, definitely not 1994. It has to be between to like professors at UC, so and so and whatever. Like that when it was the internet, but not the worldwide web. Yeah. And I'm sure like people were like kind of doing You know, like back when it was, you know, the internet, but not the worldwide web. Yeah, yeah.
And I'm shit like people were, like kind of doing transactional stuff on bulletin boards before the web was really a thing. Do you remember what the first thing you bought was? Cause I do. Oh, interesting. Well, you tell me yours while I think of mine. Yeah, because I think I know what mine might be.
I might trigger something for you. I was on CompuServe or possibly America Online. Okay. I think it was CompuServe, which would be cooler. If you say so. And I sent a $5 bill in an envelope through the mail to acquire a Magic the Gathering playing card. Wow. Yeah. Pretty good. A lot cheaper than it would have cost if I'd gone to Enterprise 1701, which was the dork store in my neighborhood where they sold Magic the Gathering cards,
which I believe they eventually did have to change that name because I'm pretty sure they were not affiliated with the Star Trek folks. I think mine is pretty similar. I was, you know, I mail order things a lot because I was super into zines and punk rock, you know, seven and singles and CDs and stuff like this. And so when the internet came to me at school, it was all about trying to find some, you know, like, school, it was all about trying to find some, you know, like, you know, cassette tape from a punk band in, you know, Gilroy, California, that I just like needed to have. So, my guess is I'm almost 100% sure it was some kind of scene, like some kind of punk rock. Sure.
Yeah. Because I was always looking for new ways. And the first things I ever did when I was online was look up guitar tabs for how to play. That was like, I just printed out guitar tabs just to learn how to play songs. And that's what I used like 90% of my internet time when I first found it. But this does remind me of something. So I went to, I started grad school in 1994.
And there was some email at Oberlin before, but no worldwide web, basically. And I was in my lab, and we had internet, and I went to, I was talking with one of my professors, and I was mentioning how I was basically downloading guitar tabs and just looking up things and downloading like little snippets of songs or whatever. And he said to me, yeah, it's really distracting. So what you should do is take the weekend and go through the whole internet and just get it out of your system and be done with it.
And then you can just get back to work. So, so, so, that is his recommendation that you could just take the weekend and just be done. Yeah, just finish it. Like I've had this with books before where I've been like really distracted thinking all the time and I just finished the book and then I'm a less obsessed with it. So do that with the internet. Exactly. I was thinking about scrolling all the way to the bottom of TikTok. I think I'm going to try to do it. I think I'm going to try to get to the end.
But that'll give you some, the question asker, Alice, some notion of what the internet was like then that it was not a completely laughable thought, even though it was a laughable thought, that you could just get through the entire internet in a weekend, because it's somebody smart who had a PhD told me that that was what could happen. So I just got interested in the card
that I bought for $5 in 1995, probably, is when this was. And it was called a Singier Vampire. And if I had had it from the Alpha edition, which was 1993, which I did not, that card would be today worth $1,200. But I had the revised, which I remember, I got it revised,
from the revised edition of the Manticle Gathering. And that card is today worth 23 cents. Wow, that's a big drop off. I was so happy. So as with most things, the one that you had probably wasn't that valuable. My kids play Magic the Gathering. One of them, in particular, is pretty obsessed.
And every time I get them a box or a pack of something, they'll go through and assess their values, which is a huge part, I think of Magic the Gathering as just assessing the values. And they'll say, well, this one is worth $30, almost pays for the whole box. And I was like, it's only worth $30. If you sell it or do something instead of keep it in a pile in your room. So go immediately.
And also, you can't sell it for $30 because you don't own a store. Exactly. That's so, maybe. Yeah. So the assess value is the magic cards have always been somewhat dubious to me. Yeah.
I mean, yes, I was legitimately surprised when I thought I saw that you could get it for 23 cents, which is kind of sad to me. That is a lot on that investment. Yeah. Do you want to give some real advice, Roman? Yeah, sure. Let's do it. It's from Steffi, I think, who asks, Dear Hengen Roman, I am a high school senior planning
to go to college next year, and I've narrowed down my decision to two schools. They are both large in-state university with a variety of majors and programs that I am interested in. And they both have good food. How should I choose between these two very similar schools? Steffanately stumped, Steffi.
It was Steffi, because Steffanately makes me think it was Steffi. How do you choose, what do you do in this situation? It was Defi because, definitely, it makes me think it was Defi. How do you do in this situation? You got two options. They're the same. You have to choose between them. I mean, because I know what I do.
Oh, interesting. So I'm hoping that she wins to both of them. You're just to check them out. Because there's more than just food. It's like, I just like spend a little time there. Yeah, I mean, because there's a vibe at each of them. So how would you choose between two similar or almost the same things?
There's a vibe, but here's what I'll say about my experience. Am I very small school? Is that there was a lot of vibes. So like you go and hang out with one group of people, it's a very different vibe from a different, there was probably like 40 different distinct vibes at a school of 2,000 people.
So here's what I do. When I vibes at a school of 2,000 people. So here's what I do. When I'm at a restaurant and they all all the stuff looks good and I'm having a hard time, I pick the cheaper one. So I think there probably will be a slightly, like a slight you apply to both these schools. At some point, somebody's gonna tell you how much they cost. I think you should go with the cheaper one. I think we don't do this enough with education.
I don't think we buy on price. We should do it more. We should put some pressure on these institutions to maybe think about how much they're charging rather than all the different food options they provide because their current trajectory is that they're just going to keep charging more forever because apparently we don't care, but I think we should care. I think that's totally true.
我觉得我们不会根据价格来买。我们应该多这样做一点。我们应该给这些机构施加一些压力，让他们考虑一下他们收取的费用到底是多少，而不是他们提供的各种不同的食物选择，因为他们目前的轨迹是他们会永远不断地收费，因为显然我们不在乎，但我认为我们应该在乎。我觉得这完全是真的。
I think I would be much more inclined to think about the area around the town. So I thought about this two Roman and then I remember my college experience when I never left campus. I really did. So I went to grad school at the University of Georgia in Athens, Georgia, and I went to... Oh, it's a nice two Athens, Georgia. To go to Athens, Georgia.
我觉得我更倾向于考虑这个小镇周围的地区。所以我之前想过两个罗马，然后我想起了我的大学经历，当时我从不离开校园。真的。所以我在佐治亚州雅典市的佐治亚大学读研究生，我去……哦，佐治亚州雅典市真好。去佐治亚州雅典市。
As much as I went to go to grad school there. I mean, I had a major professor there. I was following and I wanted to do research in his lab. But like, I would say, you know, get the local paper, or I guess it was probably not a local paper anymore, but get some kind of information. Go to the local website that they have. Go to thetown.com.
就像我去那读研究生一样。我的意思是，我在那有一位主导师。我当时在追随他，我想在他的实验室里做研究。但是，我会说，你知道的，买份当地的报纸，或者我想这可能已经不是当地的报纸了，但获取某种信息。去他们拥有的当地网站。去 thetown.com。
And compare the two as to what band or activity or thing is happening next. Just like whatever, what's the your favorite, you know, like something that you would love to go to. Yeah. And that was a huge part of my grad school experience. Let's, let's say college because I was kind of like at, I was at Oberlin and Oberlin's kind of its own community. Like you can get out to Oberlin, Ohio, but it's like, it's kind of, it's something. But like if you're in a town, which most of these big, big schools are, you know, like
并比较这两者，看看接下来会发生什么乐队、活动或事情。就像随便什么，你最喜欢的是什么，你知道的，比如你很想去的东西。是的。那是我研究生经历中很大一部分。让我们，让我们说大学，因为我有点像在，我在欧柏林，欧柏林有点像它自己的社区。就像你可以去到俄亥俄州欧柏林，但它就像，它有点，它是某种东西。但如果你在一个小镇里，这些大得多的学校大多是这样的，你知道的，比如
a bigger city or a bigger town or off and R. You know, like look for an activity and see which one like guides you a little bit is if like a band coming through a comedian coming through something like that because that's one of the things that I just loved about that time in my life was doing that sort of stuff. But I think mostly whatever you choose is going to be fine. This is the thing. This is, I mean, like, there is no decision
一个更大的城市或更大的城镇，或者经常。你知道，比如寻找一项活动，看看哪一个能引导你一点，就好像有乐队路过，喜剧演员路过之类的事情，因为那是我生命中非常喜欢那个时期的一件事，就是做那种事情。但我认为无论你选择什么都会没事的。就是这样。这，我的意思是，没有什么决定
that impacted me more in the rest of my life than where I went to college. But at the same time, it kind of wasn't that important of a decision. Like, I don't know. I would have had a very different life. But like, there was no way for me to know what the right call was.
比我去哪里上大学对我的余生产生了更大的影响。但与此同时，这个决定其实也没那么重要。就像，我不知道。我会有一个完全不同的人生。但是，我没有办法知道正确的决定是什么。
And I really, I went to the school that gave me the most money. Yeah. That, you know, I wanted to go to school in Florida because there was like a Florida specific scholarship and I wanted to go to a small liberal arts school. And I went to the one that gave me the most money. I think that's crazy. And that accepted me because several of them didn't.
我真的，我去了那所给我钱最多的学校。是的，你知道的，我想去佛罗里达上学，因为那里有佛罗里达专属的奖学金，而且我想去一所小型文理学院。我去了那所给我钱最多的学校。我觉得这太疯狂了。而且录取了我的学校，因为有几所没有录取我。
So you should definitely go to the one that accepts you. Yeah. All right. I have a question from Greta. I hope that you can advise me because my strategies are not good on this. Dear Hank and Roman, I'm currently trying to pack for a seven-day family vacation to Hawaii. Congratulations, this sounds fun. Yeah. My parents are set on not checking any bags.
所以你绝对应该去录取你的那所学校。好的。我有来自格里塔的一个问题。我希望你能给我一些建议，因为我的策略在这方面并不好。亲爱的汉克和罗曼，我目前正在为去夏威夷进行为期七天的家庭度假打包行李。恭喜，这听起来很有趣。是的。我父母坚决不托运任何行李。
And this is perfect to be a challenge for me. I'm very prepared. I'm often referred to as the mom friend. However, this seems to be a downfall in my current situation. I know that both of you have done a fair amount of traveling. This is for Hank and John, but it's true both of us as well. And I was hoping that you could give me some advice for how to pack lightly still be well prepared. I'm not great, but Greta. See, I cannot give good advice here because my strategy is to be deeply unprepared for every situation and have my wife be like,
这对我来说绝对是一个挑战。我准备得非常充分。我经常被称为妈妈朋友。然而，在我目前的情况这似乎是一个弊端。我知道你们俩都旅行过相当多的次数。这是给汉克和约翰的，但其实我们俩也一样。我希望你们能给我一些建议，教我如何轻装上阵还能准备充分。我不太擅长，不过格里塔。看，我在这里给不出什么好的建议，因为我的策略是，对每一种情况都深度不做准备，然后让我老婆觉得，
you didn't bring sunscreen, you didn't bring, you didn't bring that, you didn't, no, I'd be profan at all and I was like, no, they sell that in a Y. Yeah, that's the thing. I can get that for a dramatically increased price when you're driving away. That's the one thing, the psychological,
你没带防晒霜，你没带这个，你没带那个，你没，不，我一点也不在乎，我就像是，不，他们在夏威夷有卖的。是的，就是这样。当我开车离开时，我可以以高得离谱的价格买到那个。这就是那回事，心理上的，
like pressure release valve of this is, you always have the ability to just buy the thing, especially if you're going to Hawaii. Yeah. Sometimes you don't. Like, there are things that you can't, like get your prescription drugs. You need to bring those,
就像这个的压力释放阀，你总是有能力直接买那个东西，特别是如果你要去夏威夷的话。是的。有时候你不会。比如，有些东西你不能买，比如你的处方药。你需要带上那些，
because it's a pain in the butt to buy them when you go someplace else. Focus on everything that you can't possibly get. Another place is when you're packing is one thing. Have a list of those. Yeah. You just roll things tightly. Roll type rolls.
因为你去别的地方买它们简直是件头疼的事。专注于你绝对无法在其他地方买到的所有东西，当你打包行李时就是一回事。列一个那些东西的清单。是的。你只要把东西紧紧地卷起来。卷紧，卷。
Yeah. That is a big one. You'll focus on the things you need. I just did a vacation to Hawaii with only carry on bags and it worked out okay. You don't need a lot of things. You just need like, you know, kind of a couple of swimsuits and a couple of some clothes
是的。那是一个大招。你会专注于你需要的东西。我刚刚去夏威夷度假，只带了随身行李，结果还挺顺利的。你不需要很多东西。你只需要像，你知道的，几套泳衣和几套衣服
and most places have a few stayed in Airbnb, have places to wash things, or whatever, or you can take one of those fantastic outdoor showers and, you know, and so your rents, your stuff off. That's a cool thing. Just like, yeah, hanging over the balcony and you're going to be just fine. This does make me think this obsession with only carrying on bags is one that I don't quite understand unless you're changing a lot of plans because you're on vacation. When we travel for work, it's a cost, extra money. Now, I didn't use to, but now it does.
而且大多数地方都有一些，如果你住在爱彼迎，都有洗衣服的地方，或者随便什么，或者你可以冲个那些美妙的户外淋浴，你知道的，然后，冲洗一下你的东西。那挺酷的。就像，是的，挂在阳台上，你就会过得很好。这确实让我觉得，这种对只带随身行李的执念是我不太能理解的，除非你在度假时经常改变计划。当我们因公出差时，这是一笔成本，额外的钱。现在，我以前不会，但现在确实会。
This is the thing. This is a whole system needs to be redesigned because we are incentivizing the wrong. Now we've found some bad designs. Roman Mars is here to tell you about. I'm here to tell you about the bad design. We are incentivizing the wrong. Now we've found some bad designs. And Roman Mars is here to tell you about. I'm here to tell you about the bad design. We are incentivizing the wrong behavior. That's right. We should be paying to carry on bags and it should be free to check your bags. Because everything about the process
就是这样。这是一个整个系统都需要重新设计的问题，因为我们在激励错误的。现在我们发现了一些糟糕的设计。罗曼·马尔斯在这里向你讲述。我来告诉你关于糟糕设计的事。我们在激励错误的行为。没错。我们应该为随身行李付费，而托运寄舱行李应该是免费的。因为整个流程中的一切
of carrying on a bag, through getting through security, getting on first, finding your place and the overhead bin, all of that. And the part where suddenly you've gotten too many bags on the plane and there's no more space for them. So everybody's like, what do we do? You gotta bring the bags forward
关于随身携带行李，通过安检，最先登机，在头顶行李舱找到你的位置，所有这些。还有突然间你把太多行李带上飞机而没有更多空间给它们的那个部分。所以每个人都在想，我们该怎么办？你得把行李带到前面去
and find somebody to handle it. It's wasting everybody's time. This whole thing should be flipped. As much as you wanna make Steffi choose between her two colleges of choice because which one's cheaper? I want, you just wanna force the system to value cheaper education.
然后找个人来处理它。这在浪费所有人的时间。整件事都应该颠倒过来。就像你想让斯蒂菲在她心仪的两所大学之间做出选择，因为哪所更便宜一样？我想要，你只想强迫这个系统重视更便宜的教育。
I wanna force the system to change so that checked bags are free and carry on bags cost money because it would totally change air travel. It would be so much better. I do not wanna get on a plane first, but I pay to get on a plane first because of my stupid carry on back. I want to pay to get on the plane last, because I'm going to be on there a long time. I hate being on a plane. But the only reason that keeps me,
我想要强迫这个系统改变，这样托运的行李就是免费的，而随身行李要花钱，因为这会彻底改变航空旅行。那会好得多。我不想第一个登机，但我为了我的蠢随身行李而付钱第一个登机。我想付钱最后一个登机，因为我将在那待很长时间。我讨厌坐飞机。但唯一让我坚持的理由是，
incentivizes me to get on a plane first is that stupid carry on back. And if we just change the whole value proposition of this, air travel will be so much better for everybody. So I say, uh, stand your ground. Protests. Yeah. But as much as you want. Yeah. But all you carry on bags into one big bag and check that thing. If you're not changing planes a lot, you're going to be fine. Just like, just, just, I'm just, let's just, I want carry on to go away. Oh,. Just like, I want Karyon to go away. Oh, I would much rather get on a plane and check all my bags and just have my backpack with my computer in it.
激励我第一个登机的理由就是那个蠢随身行李。如果我们改变这一切的价值主张，航空旅行对每个人来说都会好得多。所以我说，呃，坚守你的立场。抗议。是的。但随你便。是的。把你所有的随身行李放进一个大包里，然后托运那个大包。如果你不经常转机，你会没事的。就像，就，就，我只是，我只想让随身行李消失。哦，。就像，我想要随身行李消失。哦，我宁愿上飞机把所有的行李都托运，只带着装有我电脑的双肩包。
So much easier. Yeah, that's what I do when I can do it, for sure. But this is, look, Greta is in their parents' house and they're going by their parents' rules. As long as you're living under my house, you will not check a bag. As long as you're living in the basement underneath the house part of my house,
简单多了。是的，当我能做到的时候我肯定会这么做。但这看，格里塔在他们父母的家里，他们要遵守他们父母的规则。只要你住在我的屋檐下，你就不能托运任何行李。只要你住在我家底下的地下室里，
covered under the stairs, you just like tightly roll things, splitting into two, it was a big moment for me. Like I kind of have a, you know, like the personal item, you get kind of two, you get your personal item and you get your roller bag, is to take those soft items from your suitcase that won't close that your roller bag suitcase
藏在楼梯底下，你只要把东西紧紧卷起来，分成两半，这对我来说是个大时刻。就像我有一种，你知道的，比如个人物品，你基本上能带两件，你可以带你的个人物品和你的滚轮行李箱，就是把手提箱里那些关不紧的软物品放进你的滚轮行李箱里
and just like stuff them in your back bag. Oh yeah. It's like split up the ideas. My backpack is always full of socks because I've got like my camera in there and my laptop in there and there's like hard things. And I'm like, no, you gotta throw in some padding. It's like the Styrofoam peanuts, except it's my socks.
然后把它们塞进你的背包里。哦，对。就像把主意拆分一下。我的双肩包总是塞满了袜子，因为里面有我的相机和笔记本电脑，还有一些硬东西。然后我想，不，你得塞进去一些填充物。就像聚苯乙烯泡沫塑料花生米一样，只不过是我的袜子。
And you always wear the bulkiest items, you know, like if- Wear the bulkiest items, or don't, like, this is a thing that I actually did take me a little while to learn. You don't have to bring all the bulkiest, like, some stuff takes up more space. Yeah. So just like, look and see, like,
而且你总是穿最笨重的衣物，你知道的，比如如果——穿最笨重的衣物，或者不穿，看，这其实是我确实花了一点时间才学会的一件事。你不需要带所有最笨重的，比如，有些东西确实占地方。是的。所以只要看一看，看看，
oh, that hoodie is thinner than that hoodie. And I'm also, I'm going to Hawaii, so why am I bringing up? I wear boots, like, since I was like a punk rock kid, I always like to wear boots. Yeah. And so, I feel comfortable in boots, and so you wear the boots.
哦，那件连帽衫比那件连帽衫薄。而且我也要去夏威夷，那我为什么要带上？我穿靴子，自从我还是个朋克摇滚小孩的时候起，我就一直喜欢穿靴子。是的。所以，我穿靴子感觉很舒服，所以你就穿靴子。
You don't pack boots. That's just the way it is. Yeah, I get around all this by bringing, like, by wearing the same outfit four or five days in a row, which is not what Greta wants to hear because that's not going to be helpful for them. And it really is what vacation is for, is to like do things that you wouldn't necessarily normally do
你不要打包靴子。事情就是这样。是的，我通过连续四五天穿同一套衣服来避开这一切，这并不是格里塔想听到的，因为这对他们没什么帮助。这确实是度假的目的，就是去做那些你平时不一定会做的事情
and you'll be fine. Why is it chill place. So we're the same thing over and over again. And also they've got stuff for sale. They do. Which is reminding me, this podcast is brought to you by Hawaii. They would like you to buy whatever you want there.
你会没事的。为什么是一个放松的地方。所以我们一遍又一遍地穿同样的东西。而且他们也有东西出售。确实有。这让我想起，这个播客由夏威夷赞助。他们希望你在那里买任何你想要的东西。
They've got everything. They think you shouldn't bring anything in your carry on. Just come, buy everything, get a suitcase while you're there and bring it back. This podcast is also sponsored by mid-century modern toothbrush holders. They're very skinny. That idea. Also, the podcast is brought to you by the cheapest entree on the menu. You'll see it on Hank Green's plate every time. This podcast is also sponsored by that one space chicken. When you're looking out into the velvety blackness and you see that one space chicken, your life will be made.
他们应有尽有。他们认为你不应该在随身行李中带任何东西。来吧，买下所有东西，你在那里时买个手提箱然后带回来。这个播客还由世纪中期现代牙刷架赞助。它们非常瘦。那个想法。还有，这个播客由菜单上最便宜的主菜赞助。每次你都会在汉克·格林的盘子里看到它。这个播客还由那只太空鸡赞助。当你眺望天鹅绒般的黑暗时，你看到了那只太空鸡，你的生活就会变得完美。
I don't think we'll ever look the same again. All right, before we get to the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon, I want to ask a couple of more questions. Do you use Twitter, Roman? I do. Can I ask you a Twitter question? Yeah, sure. Okay, go for it.
我想我们再也不会有同感了。好了，在我们进入来自火星和AFC温布尔登的新闻之前，我还想问几个问题。你用推特吗，罗曼？我用。我能问你一个关于推特的问题吗？行，当然可以。好吧，请问吧。
This from Nathan who asks, what is Twitter? No. Okay. I don't have any social media and my parents and friends never had Twitter. So I don't really have any frame of reference for what it is. What does everybody do on Twitter?
这是内森问的，什么是推特？不。好吧。我没有任何社交媒体，我的父母和朋友也从不用推特。所以我对它是什么真的没有任何参照框架。大家在推特上都做些什么？
Is it important? Well, why does it seem like all the famous people are on Twitter? And why they always seem to be arguing about stuff? The best I can come up with is a name-than-specific sign-off Nathan. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, Why? Okay. Okay. What is Twitter? What does one do on Twitter? Is it very important? Those are my two favorite parts. What does one do on Twitter? Here's what one does on Twitter. You you send out short thoughts that are less than 280 characters which is like
这很重要吗？嗯，为什么好像所有名人都玩推特？为什么他们好像总是在为事情争吵？我能想到的最好的回答是一个特定于内森的署名，内森。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈这可能是三句话最多，然后你把它们发出去，然后人们对你的短想法做出回应，然后你有句子最多。然后你把它们发出去，然后人们对你的短想法做出回应，然后你进行一场对话，这个对话在每次能说多少话方面是有限制的，这也许不是最好的。这确实营造了一种非常推特的特定动态。是的。这很重要吗？我打算说，在事物的资本主义“重要性”层面上，不重要。是的，如果它不存在了，世界基本上会照常运转吗，我会说会的。然而，作为虚假信息的来源，有一些不同的、非常重要的人在不同时期被拒绝使用推特，这似乎非常重要。
probably three sentences max and then you send them out and then people have responses to your short thoughts and then you have sentences max. And then you send them out and then people have responses to your short thoughts and then you have you have a conversation that is limited in how much you could say at a time, which is maybe not the best Does create us a particular dynamic that is very Twitter. Yeah. Is it important? I'm gonna say no in the capital I Importantness of of things. Yeah, like if it did not exist with the world move on pretty much as it is, I would say it would. However, as a source of misinformation, and there was some different, very important people who were denied Twitter at different times and it seemed to matter a lot.
在不同时期被拒绝使用推特的人，这似乎非常重要。所以从这个意义上说，你知道的，它是重要的，如果我们全都消失了。我不认为世界会有什么明显的改变，如果这就是你衡量重要性的标准的话，但重要性很难衡量。这是衡量重要性的一个好标准。
people who were denied Twitter at different times and it seemed to matter a lot. So in that sense, you know, that it is important, we're at all to disappear. I don't think the world would change all that appreciably and if that's how you measure importance, but it's hard to measure importance. That's a good measure of importance.
如果它消失了，什么事情是最重要的？就像空气一样，如果大气层消失了，那将是主要的那个。是的，所以大气层非常重要。是的，好吧，我的意思是除了重力之类的东西之外，对吧。我的意思是，我会说是人类制造的，你知道的，内燃机。是的，那肯定会让人遇到一些问题。是的，是的，是的。如果内燃机消失了，或者所有的汽油都消失了，
What is the thing that would matter the most if it disappeared? It's from like air, like that would be like the main one if the atmosphere disappeared. Yeah, that so the atmosphere is very important Yeah, well, I mean besides things like gravity and whatever right. I mean, I would say like human made, you know, internal combustion Yeah, which that would definitely people have some problems. Yeah, yeah, yeah. If internal combustion engines disappeared or all of the gasoline disappeared,
这一切都会相当快地停止运转。或者塑料，你知道的，诸如此类的东西会。是的，如果没有塑料，电脑将全部停止工作，真的会立即停止。所以对于推特，推特上的很多人，他们可能不需要上推特。你所提到的所有名人和重要人物，我的意思是，这有点像，你只是去占个位置，即使你并不真的需要它。而且他们大多数人真的不需要。
it would all kind of stop working pretty fast. Or plastics, you know, like things like that would be. Yeah, the computers would all stop working if there were no plastics, really immediately. So with Twitter, a lot of people on Twitter, they probably don't need to be on Twitter. All the famous and important people that you reference, I mean, that's sort of like, you sort of camp out a spot, even if you don't really need it. And most of them really don't.
我发现人们往往会经历这些使用推特的周期，在需要宣传时使用，而在不需要时则不用。我喜欢认为自己是那种人，但事实上，我是一个在过去大约10年里几乎每天都在使用推特的人。对我来说，它是最自然的社交媒体平台。我不用脸书。我的思维方式不是那种视觉化的，
And I find that people kind of go through these like, the cycles of using Twitter when they need to promote versus times when they don't. And it's just, I'd like to think of myself as that kind of person, but in fact, I'm a person who has used Twitter pretty much every day for pretty much the last 10 years. To me, it was, it's the most natural social media platform. I'm not on Facebook. I don't sort of think sort of visually,
所以我也不太擅长照片墙。对我也来说，它最像是广播，这是我那种最自然的状态。只要它保持在广播的领域内，我有一个想法，我表达出来，我会接受（你知道的）一些反馈，并与其中一些进行互动，但它不是一个双向的交流设备。而当它变成那样时，那才是推特真正崩溃的时候。如果你能把它当作一个地方，只是把关于你想法的这个信息发布到世界上，
so I'm not very good at Instagram either. And to me, it's the most like broadcasting, which is my sort of natural state of things. And as long as it stays in the realm of broadcasting, I have a thought I presented, I'll take, you know, some feedback and engage with some of it, but it is not a two way communication device. And when it does, that's when I think Twitter really breaks down. And if you can sort of just treat it as a place to just like put this message out into the world of your thoughts
它逗乐了你自己，也逗乐了少数其他人，这可以说是推特比较理想化的形式。我不能。是的，你知道你有时怎么会有离开状态吗？就像有一种方式，但也有离开的版本。我想我应该有一个推特状态，其中一个应该是，我在说话，我没在听。这就是我现在的状态。就像，不管你说什么，我都不会回应，因为我只是在说话，我没在听。但应该还有另一个状态，我是说，我只是在听，我没在说话。
and it amuses yourself and amuses a few others, that's sort of the idealized form of what Twitter is. I can't. Yeah, you know how you can have like away statuses? Like there's a way, but then there's like versions of a way. I think I should have Twitter status and one of them should be, I'm talking, not listening. That's where I'm at right now. Like, whatever you say, I'm not gonna respond to it because I'm just talking, I'm not listening. But then there should also be another one that's, I'm just listening, I'm not talking.
也许更多的人应该处于这种模式，更频繁一些。这是一个非常有趣的事情，就像推特，我想你戳中了一些东西，那就是它是一个广播平台。它并不是真正的社交媒体，因为你不是在接触与你有社交关系的人。你不是在接触朋友或家人，不像照片墙或脸书那样可能是为之设立的。
Which maybe more people should be in that mode, more often. It's a really interesting thing that like Twitter, like, I think you kind of put your finger on something there, which is that it is a broadcast platform. It's not really a social media in that you're not trying to reach the people who you are social with. You're not trying to reach friends or family, like Instagram or Facebook might be more set up for.
所以它绝对是广播，而且所有这些东西都深受其核心受众的影响，通常这些受众又受到谁先注册的影响。因此它的很多结构都是基于谁先到那里以及从那发展出来的东西。现在，并非全部。推特上当然有很多不同的板块和氛围。但有很多人认为推特非常重要，因为他们是一个自认为是重要人物的群体的一部分，就像政客、记者和（你知道的）那些做广播的人一样。他们都必须上推特。他们在互相交谈。他们在了解人们对什么感兴趣并在谈论什么，这样他们才能在新闻文章和专栏文章中谈论这些事情，并继续这种世界的进步，即以不同的方式想象事物。这很重要，但我也觉得，它有点像被冲到了一个孤岛上，与很多人的地方相当不同。是的。但如果你是一个新闻消费者，一个消费大量新闻的人，
So it is definitely broadcast and it is also like eat all of these things are so informed by their core audiences and oftentimes those are informed by like who signed up first. So a lot of the structure of it is based on who was there first and what grew out of that. Now it's not all. There's certainly lots of different sections and vibes on Twitter. But there are a lot of people who think that Twitter is very important because they are a group, a part of a group of people who imagine themselves as very important, just like politicians and journalists and, you know, people who do the broadcasty thing. And they all kind of have to be on Twitter. They are talking to each other. they are understanding what people are interested in and talking about so that they can talk about those things in their news articles and op-eds and continue this sort of,
那么就像，你和他们一起被冲到了那个岛上，我肯定是的。一样。我有点把它当作人们在谈论什么的一个过滤装置，尽管它确实有一个命中率和失误率，根据这一点有时会变得非常偏斜。但是，你知道，每个人都在谈论的文章是什么，这是一回事，但偶尔会有什么东西成为趋势，然后你会觉得，它成为趋势是因为它是趋势，
like, this part of the world's progress in imagining things differently. And that is important, but it also, I feel like, has sort of like, hosted off on its own into a land that is pretty different from where a lot of people are. Yeah. But if you're like a, like, a sort of a,
而那是成为趋势是因为它是趋势因为它是趋势。每个人都需要对一件事发表评论，是的，也许人们不需要对任何事情都发表那么多评论。你能……什么，我只是想按个按钮，把我的推特用户名改成汉克·格林，只听不讲，只听这里，只，
the news consumer, a person who consumes a lot of news, then like, you have coasted off into that land along with them, which I certainly have. Same. I kind of use it as a filtering device for like what people are talking about, although it has a real hit miss ratio that is gets really skewed sometimes based off of that. But I, you know, what is the article everyone's talking about for one thing, but then occasionally like something will trend and you're like, and it's trending because it's trending and
你知道的，不在。只是，你知道的，不在说话模式。你在哔声后留言了。是的。是的，这把整个推特变成了一个答录机。虽然我三天后才会去读推特上的任何内容。
that's trending because it's trending because it's trending. And everyone needs to comment on a thing, and yeah, maybe people don't need to comment as much about anything. What can you... What, I just want to button, that changes my Twitter handle to Hank Green, just listening, just listening here, just,
那就是，哦，天哪，那会是个很棒的推特。只要让我看三天后的推特，我当时会想，我现在对此无能为力了。它已经完成了，发生了。那样压力小多了。以前所有事情都是这样的。那是三天后的新闻，
you know, not in the. Just, you know, not in the talking mode. You've messaged after the beep. Yeah. Yeah, this is turned it all of Twitter into an answering machine. Although I read whatever's on Twitter three days later.
因为他们必须骑马才能把消息带给你。当你只是等待并看看事情如何发展时，这会改变你对时事的动态感知。我认为这可能是一件好事。有些事情，知道（你知道的）林肯总统被枪杀是很重要的，（你知道的）相当直接。但有些事情，如果能让你消化一下而不是对它们做出反应，那会很好，而推特在某种程度上助长了这种快速反应。
That's what, oh, man, that would be a great Twitter. Just show me Twitter three days later where I'm like, I can't do anything about it now. It's done, happened. It's way less stressful that way. That's how everything used to be. It was the news three days later,
我不知道这是否真的那么有帮助。接下来的问题来自彼得，他问，亲爱的汉克和罗曼，随着围绕詹姆斯·韦布空间望远镜的所有新闻和兴奋，它让我想起了我妻子想问你的一个问题，望远镜和相机有什么区别？哦，有趣。哦，高度鼓励和渴望的令人怀疑的重新定义，
because they had to get on a horse to get to you. It changes your dynamic with current events when you just wait and just see how things play out. And I think that's probably like a good thing. Some things, it's good to know that, you know, President Lincoln has been shot, you know, like pretty immediately. But like a few things, it would be good if maybe you just let them digest and so I'm reacting to them and Twitter kind of facilitates that quick reaction.
没有用棉花做尾巴，彼得，南瓜，贩卖商。是什么在捕捉图像，对吧？这才是真正的区别。是的，所以，像你所想的那样，数码单反相机是一个相机，但其实不是。它是一个附带镜头的相机。而相机是负责捕捉图像的那部分。所以哈勃空间望远镜和詹姆斯·韦布都有许多不同的相机
And I don't know if it's really that helpful. This next question comes from Peter who asks, dear Hank and Roman, with all of the news and excitement around the James Webb Space Telescope, it reminded me of a question my wife wanted to ask you, what's the difference between a telescope and a camera? Oh, interesting. Like, dubious remanations highly encouraged and desired,
或图像检测设备。然后它们在外面有一大套镜头。但你可能会问的这个问题是，相机上的所有镜头与望远镜或显微镜上的所有镜头有什么区别？而这个答案是，天哪。是的。
not tailed with cotton, Peter, pumpkin, purveyor. What is capturing the image, right? That's the real difference. Yeah, so there is, so like, what you are thinking is that like a DSLR is a camera, but it's not really. It's a camera attached to a lens. And the camera is the part that does the image capturing. So the Hubble Space Telescope and the James Webb both have a number of different cameras
是的。你们有点像所有的东西都一样。是的，它们有点像它们所做的所有相同的事情。它们基本上，它们被用来做什么？是的，这就是区别吗？是的，我在读那个问题之前都没想过这个。我想，哦，所以我有点像有一个望远镜。只是它不是一个特别好的。没错。它就坐在我的相机顶部。就像，我有一秒钟在想，哦，一个望远镜，就像你可以透过它用眼睛看一样，但并不是，因为显然哈勃空间望远镜我不能透过它去看，
or image detecting devices. And then they have a big set of lenses on the outside. But this is the question that you may be asking, what's the difference between all the lenses on a camera and all the lenses on a telescope or all the lenses on a microscope? And the answer to that is, man. Yeah.
用我自己的手来做这件事。那会令人印象深刻。在韦布所在的L2点，你知道的，我就在外面，在月球轨道之外闲逛，透过它看，做着伽利略做的事，画画并把它们发回地球。我喜欢那个问题。至少你会是第一个看到那只鸡的人。老兄，你可以这么说。你还可以发推特。
Yeah. You're kind of all the same thing. Yeah, they're kind of all the same thing that they do. They basically, what are they being used for? Yeah. Is the difference? Yeah, which I hadn't thought about until I read that question. I was like, oh, so I kind of have a telescope. It's just not a very good one. That's right. And it sits on top of my camera. Like, I thought for a second, oh, a telescope, like you can look through it and see with your eye, but no, because obviously the Hubble Space Telescope I cannot look through and
太棒了。所以你所能做的，你不能回来做采访。或者你可以做一个采访。你得走到望远镜前面去。它可以给你拍个视频。但你得离得足够远。否则你就会对不上焦。罗曼，我想再问你一个问题，
see with my own hands doing that. That would be impressive. At L2 with the web, you know, I'm like out there, beyond the orbit of the moon hanging out, looking through, doing the Galileo thing, drawing pictures and sending them back to Earth. I like that question. You'd be the first person to see the chicken at least. Dude, you can say exactly. And you can tweet about it.
因为我想知道你知不知道这个故事，这听起来，你知道的，尽管它实际上不是关于设计的，但这听起来像是一个99%隐形的故事。珍妮问，亲爱的绿发小哥们，当我年轻的时候，我有幸体验了拥有一个海猴子群落的这种似乎无处不在的体验。
Yeah, perfect. So all you can do, you can't come back to do interviews. Or you could do an interview. You'd have to go up in front of the telescope. It could take a video of you. But you have to be pretty far away. Or you'd be out of focus. Roman, I want to ask you one more question
卵装在一个小袋子里，你把它们放进水里，最终小斑点开始游动。是的，我知道海猴子是怎么回事。这怎么就成了一种现象？海猴子在自然界中自然存在吗？为什么它们装在小袋子里，还送给不负责任的小孩？
because I want to know if you know this story and this seems like, you know, even though it's not really about design, it seems like a 99% invisible story. Janine asks, dear green guys, when I was younger, I had the pleasure of experiencing the seemingly ubiquitous experience of owning a colony of sea monkeys.
我需要知道，我不完全是海猴子女王，珍妮。你对海猴子有什么了解吗？我手头没有这个故事。我知道海猴子是丰年虾。它们经历了一种可以干燥但依然存活的阶段。是的，我给它们加水，它们就打开了。这就是我所知道的，为什么它们被送给儿童，
The eggs came in a pouch and you would put in water and eventually little specks began to swim around. Yeah, I know how sea monkeys work. How do this become a thing? And do sea monkeys naturally occur in nature? Why do they come in little pouches and that are given to irresponsible children?
以及为什么它们上面画着可爱的脸，这不是我熟悉的事情。是的，这只是一种营销手段。这家伙发现在海猴子和海猴子食物可以组合进一个小袋子里，而且它们的卵会孵化。这家伙，所以我们为“通往微观世界之旅”做了一集关于这个的节目，我们不断深入挖掘，结果发现这家伙是个不折不扣的纳粹。就像海猴子的那家伙拿了他从海猴子那里赚来的钱，几乎完全用来做纳粹的事情。
I need to know not quite a sea monkey queen, Janine. Do you know anything about sea monkeys? I don't have this story at my fingertips. I know that sea monkeys are brine shrimp. They go through a sort of like a stage where they can be desiccated and still be viable. Yeah, I'd water to them, they open up. That's all I know, why they were given to children
事实上，像，他最后因为武器方面的事情陷入了法律麻烦。天哪。所以就像你能想象到的最无害的事情，海猴子，被奶昔吸管了。哇。这，我需要了解更多关于这个商店的信息。我要去寻找更多关于那个的信息。这太神奇了。这太神奇了。是的，我自己也非常
and why they drew cute faces on them is not something I'm familiar with. Yeah, it was just a marketing thing. This guy figured out that you could combine sea monkeys and sea monkey food into a pouch and that their eggs would hatch. And this guy, so we did an episode of Journey to the Microcosmos about this and we kept going further and further down the rabbit hole and it turns out that this guy is, was a legit Nazi. Like the monkey's guy took that money that he made from CMUNKIES and he did almost exclusively Nazi stuff with it.
吃惊。是的。它最初叫“即时生命”，售价49美分，但这家伙在1962年把名字改成了海猴子。然后他发现漫画书营销是一种接触大量人群的真正廉价的方式，他在60和70年代成为了典型的漫画书营销人员。所以我也养过海猴子。你养过海猴子吗？我从来没养过。
In fact, like, he ended up being in legal trouble for like arms stuff. Oh my God. So like the most innocuous thing you can imagine, the CMUNKIES, got milkshake duct. Wow. That's, I need to know more about this store. I'm going to go find more about that. That's amazing. That's amazing. Yeah, I was very
它们从来没有真正吸引过我。但其他在漫画书背面与它共享页面的东西，我非常渴望。我也从来没能得到那些，但X光眼镜，是的。以及各种其他的解码器戒指之类的东西。我想要其中的每一个，从来没有，从来没能得到那些。是的。这感觉有点像在互联网上买东西。
surprised myself. Yes. It was it was initially called Instant Life and it was sold for 49 cents, but they changed this guy changed the name to sea monkeys in 1962. And then he figured out that like comic book marketing was sort of a really inexpensive way to reach a lot of people and he was became the kind of quintessential comic book marketer in the 60s and 70s. So I also had C. Monkeys growing up. Did you have C. Monkeys? I never had them.
非常相似，在过去的日子里，你把一张崭新的5美元纸币塞进信封，贴上邮票，把它寄给另一个想要扑克牌的小孩。那是美好的时光。是的，威尔金斯交出现金就像我跨州进行第一笔交易的方式一样。好了，罗曼，是时候播报来自火星和AFC温布尔登的新闻了。如果你没有听过这个播客，因为你只是罗曼·马尔斯的粉丝，AFC温布尔登是我哥哥痴迷的一支英格兰第三级别足球队，而火星是一个
They didn't ever really appeal to me. But other stuff that it shared the page with on the back of the comic book, I desperately wanted. I never could get those either, but X-rays backs in, yeah. And various other decoder rings and stuff. I wanted every single one of those things, never, never managed to get those. Yeah. It feels a little bit like buying something on the internet.
行星。它是第四颗行星。它很冷。它很尘土飞扬。它是红色的。我对AFC温布尔登略知一二，因为我最近参加了我妈妈的70岁生日派对，所以我跟约翰在一起。
Very similar back in the day when you put a crisp $5 bill into an envelope, put a stamp on it and mailed it to some other child Yeah, who had a playing card you wanted That's a good time. Yeah, Wilkins yield cash is like how I did my first transactions across state lines All right Roman it's time for the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon If you haven't listened to this podcast because you're just a Roman Mars fan, A.I.C. Wimbledon is a third-tier English soccer team that my brother is obsessed with and Mars is a
新闻很糟糕。哦，不。这，整整一年都像是在坐过山车，因为最开始的时候。就像是第一年没有任何降级风险，一切都进展顺利。有很多平局，但事情进展顺利。我一直在关注。
planet. It's the fourth planet. It's cold. It's dusty. It's red. I know vaguely about A.I.C. Wimbledon because I was, as my mom's 70th birthday party recently and so I was hanging out with John.
然后，你知道的，像，在过去的几个月里有所回升。这太吓人了。是的，他们目前正处于联赛过去大约10年来最长的连败之中。哇。他们在第80分钟时以一比零领先。然后他们输了，顺便说一句，足球比赛
And the news is bad. Oh no. It was, this whole year has been a real roller coaster because of the very beginning. It was like the first year in which there was no relegation like risk and everything was doing well. It was a lot of ties, but things were doing well. And I was following along.
是90分钟长。他们以三比一输了。哦，天哪。那是……所以他们就像是在最后10分钟里，对方球队进了三个球。这太令人心碎了。这太令人心碎了。
And then, you know, like, pick up in the last few months. And it's just scary. Yeah, they have, they are currently in the midst of the longest no-win streak in the last like 10 years of their league. Wow. And they were up one to zero in the 80th minute. And then they lost, soccer games, by the way,
我和约翰在房子里，他说，幸好我对足球比赛的结果不再有负面情绪了。好吧。所以整个赛季就像是，就像是一场进展顺利的比赛被炸毁了，因为，对。是的。你知道，据约翰说，他们以臭名昭著著称，就像当他们领先时，你知道，他们不能先进球，然后他们，然后他们就输了。
are 90 minutes long. They lost three to one. Oh my goodness. That's... So they're like in the last 10 minutes, the other team scored three goals. That's heartbreaking. It's heartbreaking.
整个赛季，他们都是先进球的。现在他们在开始时表现不错。现在他们只是，是的，是的，好吧，听到这个消息很难受。看起来不太妙。截至本期录制时，他们仍然在降级区之外，但也只是勉强而已。我以为他们赢了那场比赛，因为我爸爸说，哦，他温布尔登一比零
And I was in the house with John, and he was like, good thing I don't feel negative emotions about football outcomes anymore. Okay. So this whole season has been like, like, it's sort of blown up game that went well in place because, right. Yeah. You know, according to John, it's a notorious for like when they go up, you know, they can't score first, then they, then they lose.
因为他在还剩80分钟的时候看了一眼。然后他就想，好吧，就像，就像，我假设那会进展顺利的。不管怎样，这不太好。但在来自火星的新闻中，好消息，非常激动人心，非常有趣。毅力号火星车即将进行它的第一次，类似于真正长途的驾驶。
And the whole season, they scored first. And now they did well in the beginning. And now they just, yeah, yeah, well, it's tough to hear. It's not looking great. There's still out of the relegation zone as of this recording, but only just. And I thought that they won that game because my dad said, oh, he's humilded one
所以它将要驾驶，所以它已经在那呆了一大大约一年了。它即将开到一个三角洲，那个三角洲流入了它所在的陨石坑中。为了到达那里，它必须绕到一片岩石多且沙子多的区域。它们不想在那里驾驶。这将是一次三英里长的驾驶。
because he just looked at it when there was 80 minutes in. And he was like, well, like, like, I assume that's gonna go out okay. Anyway, it's not great. But in the news from Mars, great news, very exciting, very interesting. Perseverance Rover is about to go on its first, like real long drive.
他们将要进行那三英里长的驾驶。他们对这一点以及他们的语言以及他们如何谈论它非常具体。这将比以往任何火星车行驶三英里的速度都要快。因为他们需要让它听起来相当快。而且确实相当快，但这需要30天才能行驶三英里，因为他们需要让它听起来相当快。而且确实相当快，但这需要30天才能行驶三英里。但那非常快。是的。
So it's gonna drive, so it's been a, it's been there about a year. It's about to drive up to a delta that sort of spilled into the crater that it's in. And to get there, it has to sort of drive around to this area that's sort of rocky and sandy. They don't want to drive on. It's gonna be a three mile long drive.
一路上会有一些停顿。这比好奇号做同样事情的速度要快得多，因为毅力号实际上可以自行驾驶相当长的一段距离，你只要说，去这里，它就能环顾四周并选择一条没有一堆会让自己卡住的岩石或沙子的路线。所以它更懂得如何做事，我们不需要对它进行太多控制。这真的很酷。而且行驶三英里是为了到达这个新地方，是为了研究某些特定东西，还是仅仅为了跑三英里？那到底是什么？为了到达，不，是的，我刚才让它走了。现在是为了到达三角洲。
And they're gonna do that three mile long drive. They're very specific about this and their language and how they talk about it. It's gonna be faster than any rover has ever driven three miles before. Because they need it to sound like it's quite fast. And it is quite fast, but it is gonna take 30 days to go three miles before because they need it to sound like it's quite fast. And it is quite fast, but it is going to take 30 days to go three miles. But that's very fast. It is.
所以，所以一个三角洲，所以这是河流流入湖泊的地方，基本上它沉积了一层又一层又一层的沉积物，是通过所有这些不同的层来观察该地点地质历史的好地方。它也是一个潜在的好地方，可以找到你意想不到的东西，无论那些可能是什么。显然，三角洲通常是在地球上找到化石、找到先前生物学证据的好地方，你知道的，我想毅力号很乐意发生这种事。
And there will be some stops along the way. And it's a lot faster than how curiosity would do the same thing because perseverance can actually drive itself a fair amount where you just say, go here and it can look ahead of itself and kind of choose a path that doesn't have a bunch of rocks that it's going to get stuck on or sand that's going to get stuck on. So it knows more about how to do stuff and we don't have to be in control of it as much. It's really cool. And the driving three miles is to get to this new place, is to study something in particular, is it just to do three miles? What is the? It's to get, no, yeah, the moment I just make it go. Now it's to get to the delta.
它们只是在里面找到了一只鸡，但我们不是像，呃，美国宇航局从来没有像那样说过这个目标，因为它们不是像，我们不是在尝试。我们不是像，你知道的，我们以前被坑过，但它们都非常，它们都非常好奇，呃，生命在宇宙中有多普遍。如果它在一个太阳系中进化了两次，那将是（你知道的）从一个n等于1到一个n等于2的相当显著的扩张，这是一件大事。那真的是一件大事。
So, so a delta, so this is where a river flowed into a lake basically and that lays down layers and layers and layers of sediment and is a great place to see the geological history of the spot by all those different layers. It's also potentially a great place to find things that you wouldn't expect to see whatever those may be. Obviously, Delta's are often a great place to, on Earth, to find fossils, to find evidence of previous biologies, which is, you know, I think the perseverance would love to have happened.
所以，所以三角洲，这基本上就是河流流入湖泊的地方，它会一层又一层地沉积下厚厚的沉积物，是通过所有这些不同的层来了解该地点的地质历史的绝佳场所。这也可能是一个绝佳的地方，可以找到你意想不到的东西，无论那可能是什么。显然，在地球上，三角洲通常是寻找化石、寻找先前生物学证据的好地方，你知道的，我认为毅力号会很乐意遇到这种情况。
They're just fine like a chicken in there, but we're not like, uh, and that NASA never sort of like says that goal because they're not like, we're not trying it. We're not like, you know, we've been burned before, but they're all very, they're all very curious about how, uh, common life is in the universe. And if it evolved to twice in one solar system, that would be a pretty significant expansion of the, you know, going from an end of one to an end of two is a big deal. That is a very big deal.
它们在里面就像一只鸡一样安然无恙，但我们并不是，呃，而且美国宇航局从来没有真正把这个目标挂在嘴边，因为他们不是那种，我们不想尝试。我们不是那种，你知道的，我们以前吃过亏，但他们都非常，他们都对宇宙中生命的普遍程度感到非常好奇。如果它在一个太阳系中进化出了两次，那将是一个相当显著的扩展，你知道的，从一个样本变成两个样本是一件大事。那可真是一件大事。
One is a universe, this big. So who knows? And it's a big solar system. There's other places we haven't been that are prime and interesting places for life to maybe happen. So they're just hard to get to because they're under giant sheets of ice around and moons around gas giants. But yeah, super stoked for the Curator for the perseverance team doing doing this drive.
一个是这么大的宇宙。谁知道呢？这是一个很大的太阳系。还有其他地方我们没有去过，这些地方可能是孕育生命的主要且有趣的地方。所以它们只是很难到达，因为它们在巨大的冰层下面，在气态巨行星的卫星周围。但是，是的，非常为“好奇号”和“毅力号”团队进行这次行驶感到兴奋。
So keep your eye out over the next month. There's going to be a lot of movement on Mars. You can check on the map at JPL's website. Just search for Rover Drive probably. I think you're not you're not a use the internet. Yeah. Roman, thank you're not. You're not a user. You're not a user. Roman, thank you so much for making a podcast with me. I assume that everybody who listens to this knows about 99% visible,
所以请留意接下来的一个月。火星上将会有很多动态。你可以在喷气推进实验室的网站上的地图上查看。大概只需搜索“漫游车行驶”。我想你不是——你不是一个互联网用户。是的，罗曼，谢谢你——你不是。你不是一个用户。你不是一个用户。罗曼，非常感谢你和我一起做一个播客。我假设听这个节目的每个人都知道《99% Invisible》，
but if you don't, you've heard enough that you're going to go check it out now. I assume. I would hope so, and I hope that anyone's here in this who is here because of me goes and checks out the rest of your hangin' John because it really is the thing that gives my my kids the most joy. That's so cool. Yeah, a lot. A really good one.
但如果你不知道，你已经听了足够多的内容，现在就会去查看它了。我猜是的。我希望如此，我也希望任何因为我而来到这里的人，都能去看看你和约翰的节目，因为它确实是给我孩子们带来最多快乐的事情。太酷了。是的，很多。真的是个好节目。
Well, I'm happy that you are, have a productive relationship with your teenage sons. I am crossing my fingers that in 10 years, I productively listen to podcasts with a person who I have a good relationship with Yeah, it's a nice thing And it's like one of those things that starts a little conversation We hear a thing then somebody reaches forward and pauses and says give their answer of like how many lemons a person would be made out of or something And and they may unpause it and then we can be continuous though
嗯，我很高兴你和你的十几岁儿子们有着富有成效的关系。我祈祷在十年后，我能和一个我关系很好的人一起有生产力地听播客。是的，这是一件美好的事情。这就像那种能开启一小段对话的事情，我们听到一件事，然后某人伸手向前按下暂停键，给出他们的回答，比如一个人是由多少个柠檬组成的之类的，然后他们可能会取消暂停，然后我们可以继续
If you're if you're listening Marsins, I want you to guess how many chickens you think there could be in a cubic light ear before we'd notice. That's a good one. And then we can have some astrophysicists come on bone that as well. Perfect. Be very curious to find out.
如果你在听，火星人，我想让你猜猜，在我们在我们注意到之前，一个立方光年里可能会有多少只鸡。这是一个好问题。然后我们可以请一些天体物理学家来讨论这个问题。完美。非常好奇想知道结果。
I was a real pleasure. Thank you so much. If you want to send us questions, you can do that. Our email address is hankandjohnatgmail.com. We don't have a podcast without your questions. So we appreciate everybody who sends them in. This podcast is edited by Joseph Tuna Meta. She's produced by Rosie on a Halsey Rojas. Our communication coordinator is Julia Bloom, our editorial assistant, who helps me with things like the facts of my ask. We didn't get to this
这真是个荣幸。非常感谢。如果你想给我们发问题，你可以这样做。我们的电子邮件地址是hankandjohnatgmail.com。如果没有你们的问题，我们就没有播客。所以我们感谢每一个发信的人。这个播客由约瑟夫·图纳·梅塔剪辑。她由罗斯·奥纳·霍尔西·罗哈斯制作。我们的交流协调员是朱莉娅·布鲁姆，我们的编辑助理，她帮我处理诸如事实核查之类的事情。我们没有谈到这个问题
question. What percent foot am I? Like what percent of my body is foot? The answer is about 3%. So, Deboki helped answer that question for us. That's why we need her. The music you're hearing now, and at the beginning of the podcast is by the great gunnerola, and as they say in our hometown. Don't forget to be awesome. Dear Hank and John is available wherever you get podcasts, it will make your life better. You should definitely subscribe.
问题是：我几分之几是脚？就像我的身体有多少比例是脚？答案大约是 3%。所以，德博基帮我们回答了这个问题。这就是为什么我们需要她。你现在听到的以及播客开始时的音乐是由伟大的冈内罗拉创作的，正如我们家乡常说的那样。别忘了做个了不起的人。《亲爱的约翰和汉克》在任何能收听播客的地方都可以听到，它会让你的生活变得更好。你绝对应该订阅。
99% of visible is Delaney Hall, Crick Colesde, Martin Gonzales, Swansea, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Barubek, Christopher Johnson, Lashemba Dawn, Jason Dalyone, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of the Stitcher & Serious XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and at show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and ready to. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love,
《99% Invisible》的成员有德兰尼·霍尔、柯里克·科尔斯德、马丁·冈萨雷斯、斯旺西、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、维维安·李、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯·巴鲁贝克、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉舍姆巴·道恩、杰森·达利翁、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。我们是 Stitcher & Sirius XM 播客大家庭的一员，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼往北六个街区，位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上@我 @RomanMars，也可以@节目 @99PI org。我们在 Instagram 和 ready 上。你可以找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，
as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don't Don Don't Don't Don't Don Don Don't Don't Don't Don't Don Don't Don Don't Don't Don Don Don't Don Don Don't Don't Don't Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don Don There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及《99%PI》过去的所有剧集，网址是 99PI.org。别……本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。